j'ai voulu devenir commentateur sportif
par par passion par par transmission si
le fait de transmettre cette passion
autour du sport qui accompagne ma vie
depuis le plus jeune âge mon meilleur
souvenir de commentateur sportif je
pense et l'arrivée du relais 4 x 100 m
nage libre aux jeux olympiques de
londres 2012 où les français ont réussi
à battre les américains non seulement
les américains mais également toutes les
autres équipes un dernier relais de
yannick agnel lui dire je m'en
souviendrai toute ma vie j'ai la raison
pour laquelle je m'en suis ray c'est
parce que yannick ce jour là m'a soufflé
à l'oreille tu es comme notre cinquième
meilleur ça ce sont des souvenirs qui ne
s'effaceront jamais
eh bien tant que le temps que le public
me fait confiance qui ce qui semble être
le cas d'après les sondages que je peux
lire à droite et à gauche je continuerai
je pense que tant que j'aurai cette
cette passion justement dont je parlais
il ya quelques instants
je continuerai cette année j'ai la
chance d'être sur le dispositif du tour
de france cycliste donc je pense que ça
devrait se poursuivre au cours des
prochaines années et puis naturellement
nous avons quand même c'est très très
belle perspective des jeux olympiques de
tokyo 2021 et puis ensuite de paris 2024
ce sera une si jolie manière de tirer sa
révérence peut-être